this is a production of Cornell
University okay so with that just a
couple of words about taking care of
yourself the National Association of
landscape professionals on Twitter on
the web addressing the issues right
everybody's short-staffed everybody's
running around it's a normal spring plus
there's a lot of concern about our
health and safety and and those of our
loved ones right so that's feels like
burning the candle at both ends to me so
I think anything we can do to support
ourselves our mental health as well as
our physical health and mental health
often gets neglected but of course
incredibly important and we hope that
the thirty minutes we've been able to do
the last couple of months have been a
part of whatever has been helping you
get through what we're going through so
let's do a little weather we remain well
behind right I mean this is where Utah
is right page up at 4,000 feet it's
still pretty cold up there so for us
it's really well behind normal and this
is entirely unexpected by the middle of
May I mean we were on pace early on in
late March and early April to see the
growing season advanced significantly I
have not been able to really see in
advance much in fact we're only expected
to be normal if you look at the amount
of heat we're gonna accumulate obviously
you see we're well into this the double
digits now 50 to 70 growing degree days
penetrating well into upstate New York
but look at much of northern New England
northeast eastern end of Long Island you
can see still not much accumulation it
will be normal
our our climate condition our weather or
forecasts are calling for normal and
remember last week it was 20 to 25
degrees below normal for this time of
year I was talking about snow we had on
Wednesday now we'll start our
conversation with Paige I'm not going to
get into much else beyond the
conversation with this with the scholar
about the
fix that she's working on and and this
is where to start right a lot of things
that are happening in the soil you could
see a month ago we were looking really
progressing really far we were getting
into the mid-50s Lauro to mid 50s and if
you look at more localized soil
temperatures in the urban areas in
southeast New York you'll certainly see
a lot warmer temperatures than this data
will present but you know in early April
it look like okay we're moving on and
then may you can see it took us a whole
month to just get ten more degrees and
now you can see we're tracking air
temperature to a certain extent and
still right in the low 50s now we're
expecting a big surge of warmth and rain
coming through that we'll see some big
push in moisture and in soil temperature
and of course Paige and her colleagues
this is like who's who with Dan Potter
on their page that was uh had to be
quite a thing to get damn I'm working on
this published last year in pest
management science I believe this was
pest management science was good page
yes okay and in this article it's just a
wonderful review article of the ecology
you know how these things behave you
know what are we talking it's not what
an earthworm they gave different ways
and effigy and og is and II forget if
age I've become a worm scholar just prep
preparedness today as cop mentioned
everything that listen this has been a
nuisance
I would I would characterize this as a
nuisance something that we've had a lot
of different ways of dealing with this
sort of class of pests called worms
right we call them earthworms but
there's a whole bunch of them but this
is the one now that in the beds that
it's in and in the Long's that it's
penetrating into is starting to be a
problem so let's let's set up for you
know let's see if we can do about ten
minutes fifteen minutes on this and I
want to do about ten fifteen minutes on
the clover so I'll
keep an eye on the watch cos we can go
deeper so to speak on worms let's start
with this page you know that one of the
things we hear oh ah our earthworms a
sign of a good spoil are they a sign of
a good soil really I think worms are
pretty prolific everywhere at this point
so okay so that's right because you know
you hear oh wow I got worms
this is a good thing especially in home
lawns right especially in home lawns now
I mentioned the Asian jumping worm you
talked about many species is it one of
the things we're used to here in the
Northeast with regard to soil insects so
to speak or soil animals if you will is
that white grubs especially in the
metropolitan New York area really up
into Rochester in all the major cities
have more than one white grub species as
you go west the scarab beetle population
is mostly [ __ ] beetles or June beetles
and then you come this way we have five
different kinds right is that the same
thing when it comes to worms and does
that make it sort of difficult to manage
them yeah it's very rare to just have a
single species in a soil normally
there's probably on average at least
maybe three or four species in one given
area and because they all behave
differently there are species
differences and so some of them might
burrow some of them may be kind of
dwellers at the G X and so that makes it
really difficult to control these if you
are finding them to be nuisance because
some of them might be able to escape
some of the products you're putting down
or down deep in the soil to avoid
environmental conditions that are
favorable and they can enter into a
dialogue and of a hibernation state so
it does make things really really
difficult especially if you do have a
mix which and so you have this myriad of
behavior we're seeing this one species
this Asian jumping worm species now Kyle
wicking czar professor wicking czar our
soil insect ecologist has looked at some
just some simple work of you know mulch
and a bed and a lawn you know will there
be a feeding preference for the way they
move you know that's one that we're
wondering about controlled but what
about food source let's talk about food
I mean it seems like okay they've
ravaged everything in the bed and now
they're having been along just because
it's there not because they necessarily
prefer it so let's talk a little bit
about is there a realistic way to manage
where these worms are from a food source
perspective in the lawn landscape even
if you do remove the organic matter or
lower the organic matter through all
these different management practices the
earthworms are gonna stay there they
can't move that much so they're going to
potentially be eating more because they
still need to get that organic food
which means they're gonna be casting
more and all this so so what about this
one worm dominating I mean if I'm I
think the thing the big concern is okay
you know okay I get it there's lots of
worms and now we got this one guy just
doesn't want to play nice with anybody
else seems to dominate these systems so
I'm wondering
you know what you feel about these be
things becoming quote-unquote you know
not Lee but be hating as with invasive
properties each Coast but most of the
ones that we think of when we think of
an earthworm Europeans because
earthworms aren't native to the US in
those cases they don't mean inherently
that means inherently that means when
you say that means okay great that means
there isn't any natural predators or
things that we can rely on to key these
population to check yes again that was
kind of a golf course standpoint where
you know that might be a little more
feasible there just isn't research on it
we don't know for for as much as we know
about everything in turf right now and
let's feel like earthworms have not been
researched very heavily no because right
and in your article and listen I've been
around long enough we were used hurry
I am the guys that I was working with
were spraying lead arsonate and Bourdain
and when you put that stuff down you
don't have to worry for I don't know a
decade twenty years until you bury it
and what happened is over time
listen historically st. Andrew's I've
seen pictures I tried to pull up
pictures see if I could get some really
gross ones of old guys I saw the late
Jim beard give a talk beard give a talk
at an international conference in the
90s where he talked about this worm
issue I mean it literally almost
destroyed the golf business in in in st.
Andrews I mean the worms were so
prolific because of the compost they
were adding and all this other stuff now
historically that's what we did we
away with there for a little while now
we see a big resurgence of installing
compost back into lawns is that
literally seeding our lawns with worms
you smoke so if you have those cocoons
or those worms they can enter your lawn
that way a lot of people will just dump
their fishing
[Music]
[Music]
parthenogenesis without me and so you
get one cocoon in there that can have
you know a couple worms maybe
potentially okay so let's wrap this
little part up here before we talk about
clover and ask about control you know
Dan's work with the saponified materials
right really change the game
you know Williamson back in the day when
he left and he was he was she studying
blackjack stuff that the flyest and all
types of irritants like the deep sand
top dressing in the Pacific Northwest
but the easy go-to in the lawn is an
insecticide well if I maybe I can
suppress them with this or worse sorts
of things or so let's is it reasonable
to think in a lawn situation you're
going to get control in these soil based
systems easily
[Music]
and selectively so those products are
not gonna get in those cocoons they are
resistant to he desiccation and all that
so even if you control the population
that's currently active you're not going
to get long-term control because once
conditions are favorable again those
cocoons are going to hatch and if you
have those worms so we're just going to
take repeated very consistent control
measures which in a lot of cases is not
feasible either economically or you know
logistically and so raise the height of
cut raise the height of cut hope the
jumping worms don't turn the soil into
ball bearings yeah that the mower sinks
I have to get a picture my wife
maintains a property by the lake that
has has the worms that have made it out
into the lawn and it's quite a sight you
know I've never seen it to be that bad
and this thing seems resistant to
everything
if this because it's living into bed and
the lawn I think just in the lawn we
might be able to get away with it cuz
you know how to cut and maybe the soil
won't be so devastated but the landscape
beds are horrific Paige I mean in any of
your work teach you anything about what
they can do where they're constantly
throwing mulch and beds just just seems
like a breeding ground for it know
whatever kind of horror stories about
everything I mean just destroy the soil
destroy beds destroy the plants I mean
yeah there's really just not a good
control option right now the sapiens
which we're really popular aren't being
produced right now or at least aren't
being marketed in the US anymore so
that's our biggest control measure taken
away in the last you know five or six
months again I the pesticides can be
effective but I hate recommending them
because they aren't labeled for
earthworm use and so it's it's difficult
and in the flowerbeds I mean they're
picking up the hostas and walking away
with them there's there's so many of
them there so listen Carl did we get any
worm questions while while we've been
talking cuz I want to get to the clover
part now
yeah no worm questions so far so you
know I did actually have a question so
we always we've done golf course turf
shorter cut turf we're worried about the
castings and that's really what's
causing the problems the mowers going
over it it's smearing it is there any
way we can get the worms to maybe go
throw their castings somewhere else you
know maybe we don't have to control the
worms but control how they you know put
their castings up by the surface to make
the cast more sandy so they aren't
smearing mowers and and let me let me
make let me commend let me commend that
article pages review article again to
everybody because in there she talks
about the casting the casting
characteristics that these different
species have some more or less conducive
and I've seen you know talking about
golfing you know on Long Island where
you've got sandy lawns if somebody's
coming in and bringing topsoil to grow a
lawn that might you know maybe it's good
to try to grow the grass on the sand if
if worms can be a problem and you might
be installing that there but you know
the combination of top dry some irritant
maybe an insecticide that or a fungicide
that you're targeting but no one's gonna
do that in a lawn right i I really
wanted you to come on and say to me what
I thought which is yeah good luck with
this I mean we need so much more
research in this area because worms and
a right level in a lawn and landscape
can be beneficial in the churning and
building and managing of organic matter
right [ __ ] yeah they can be there the
castes are really high and really
concentrated in organic matter and
nutrients and all of that available
nutrients in a lot of cases so they can
be beneficial but yeah this is jumping
worm in particular yeah it surprised you
yeah okay so listen let's talk let's try
a transition to clover and the forecast
that I mentioned also forecasts the way
we think about broadleaf weed control at
this time now Paige this is part of our
discussion right when we're talking
about clover is okay you want to have a
flowering law and let's talk about the
melding of the traditional lawn with
with with the idea of a flowering or
clover lawn like you're talking about
and the thing we recommend generally are
these the model that was developed out
of Purdue for timing in the springtime
you wonder about the accuracy of this in
a year that's been so delayed and slow
in the spring and for those of you that
don't know about our forecast website
you can have a dandelion dashboard your
own based on a zip code that will give
you favorable times for using products
that could provide some broadleaf weed
control and so I just wanted to set the
context with you page that you know I've
been thinking about this low input lawn
thing for the 30 years of my career and
these every once in a while these
obscure papers come out this one from
the Czech Republic where they looked at
you know an Ilana did you sort of mold
left the clippings and fertilized it
differently for a cup for ten years this
was 10 years of either collecting or
mulching mowing and then no fertilizer
essentially one pound or two pounds I
would call the home lawn you know one
application two applications a year and
a couple of things are fascinating here
and setting up the context you know
looking at a research study that shows
what happens in a lawn you know if you
look at the legumes that clover would be
a part of the place where you see them
really suppressed is where clippings are
returned right and that would be an
indication of maybe
um something happening because I would
have thought also that with
fertilization you might see some
suppression but you see the largest
expanse of the grass the grass itself
the grass is in itself in these lawns
where they mulch mode now if you look at
the species representation they are just
a grass part right let's go back the the
you know 60 to 70 percent of these lawn
types are grasses and then the other 30
is dispersed between legumes weeds and
bare ground and and obviously you see
you know where you water but you don't
fertilize you've got Kentucky bluegrass
right you've got Kentucky bluegrass up
here and then the finally fescues and
some bent grass right well you irrigate
and you fertilize a lot and you see you
get Kentucky bluegrass perennial rye and
annual bluegrass and in this case they
know it behaves like a perennial because
you're irrigating it and not
experiencing the drought stress and then
you go to uh Neera gated sort of just
mode and now you see turf type tall
fescues hard fescue and red fescue in in
the grass mix now I bring this up page
because you know everybody imagines a
sort of a nice uniform clover lawn like
this and this was what we talked about
years and years ago you look at an old
seed catalog from 1895 and they're
talking about clover regularly included
in the seed mixes then you go to Amazon
and Amazon is now selling or Scots is
selling a clover lawn now I had a
difficult time I couldn't get what was
in this but what I thought was very
interesting page is they say there's
strawberry clover in there I didn't know
this was something you could get now
also in the context of this discussion
is these flowering lawns right this is
the Florida lon
that that is sold by a pure turf pro
turf proteins lawn seed or something and
you can see here there's a white clover
and then this Rogerian so I thought that
was interesting I thought that was hard
to get and then Eric Watkins in his lab
with his graduate students I'm assuming
and maybe another faculty member looked
at the establishment of cura clover
trifolium and big young in these lawns
and they just published this last year
now I took this little quote out of
there because I actually thought it to
be the key part of our discussion which
is you know it's one thing to get these
things established right but essentially
we're talking about managing these
managing these areas right not just
simply you know not just simply planting
them but managing them now here's some
of your work that you've been tweeting
about I've been so interested in this
watching this come about but one of the
issues that we face is you know
sometimes clover doesn't play nice now
on athletic fields it could or couldn't
have its issue but how it becomes patchy
long term and the questions about
managing other plants out of it so let's
start with the general discussion you're
in Utah I'm thinking this has got to be
something about water so let's start
with maybe the way you're approaching or
maybe that's not right so I am I threw a
whole lot of stuff out there we can talk
about how you want to unpack it but
let's start with just a simple will
stuff what are you doing out there now
what kind of stuff are you looking at
yeah so the biggest issue that I see
with a lot of the research is that it
does focus primarily on white clover
which is not super drought tall I mean
it'll kind of come and go and they have
potential and so I'm looking at white
clover kind of as the industry norm
strawberry clover as well because it
does seem to be a popular one but I'm
also looking
settings so crimson clover and rose
clover which is actually used pretty
pretty exclusively from what I can tell
in vineyards in California and those
would be characterized by less frequent
mowing right once you get into the
pasture setting you know colder seems to
respond in a funky way to mowing cuz I
have it in my fields here with my pigs
and our fields we don't fertilize them
you know and they wind up with a lot of
clover and I've seen clover that you
know somebody would probably tell me is
Micro clover honestly I just think it's
what happens what clover does when you
trim it closely like that is that your
sense of some of this yeah actually
pretty okay very rarely gets up to that
three inch the white clover obviously
gets crazy and so I pull a lot off there
but it comes back so these you know one
of the things I wanted a reason I wanted
to talk about this in a lawn or
landscape session is because you know
you wonder if this isn't something maybe
we should start rethinking introducing
back into the lawns I saw that you used
that sort of scalping establishment
method is that that to me I love it
personally it's you know opening it up
and doing that so I'm wondering how you
like establishing it and I want to talk
about what you think with regard to sort
of the way it evolved and managing it
longer term that would be speculation I
suspect yeah so last year this trial
just with bare soil we see at the same
time
and just kind of let it all grow up the
clover really took over like very
heavily it was almost you know 70 80
percent clover in most cases which is an
ideal I mean you still want the grass
there to provide some of the you know
resiliency against traffic or whatever
the case may be so this year we decided
to kind of restart the trial we went in
and we scalped because that seems to be
kind of the what the research suggests
is the easiest and best way to do it so
I cut the same seeding rate we went in
scalped it all down and then a couple
days later when it unseated and it's
actually working out really well right
now I think it's a good way to just
anyone can scout that's right that's
right so many people it's their
preferred way of right and now okay
so part of it is no one's saying that
every plant that lawns gotta be clover
we're looking for these mixed species
and I'm wondering about transitioning
from the lawns we have to the lawns
maybe that have these clover and even
other plants in them let's start with
the kinds of shifts you think you're
gonna make are you gonna fertilize your
clover lawns the same way number one
looking at with this trial so half of
each of those mixtures we have plots
that are going to be fertilized and Plus
that are not going to be fertilized and
we're gonna see kind of how that affects
the mixtures but also with the turf and
because again we do want to keep that
turf there so if we're fertilizing the
turf is it going to take over clover if
we're not fertilizing is clover going to
take over the turf or vice versa some of
that research has been done on white
clover there's a lot of research showing
that or at least looking at fertilizer
and how it affects clover white clover
but a lot of that isn't known for some
of these other species that have
potential and so
that's that's one aspect that we're
looking at with this is kind of how
those mixtures are going to change based
on different and as we wrap up that's
fast 30 minutes you know other it's not
like Culver's gonna be the only plant
there you may get dandelion you may get
ground ivy you may get winter annuals I
can be you may have crabgrass issues I
know McElroy is published a little bit
on herbicide aspects this is really
going to complicate things there's a
little bit of wiggle room in that to 4d
doesn't necessarily bother clover all
the time I've seen it damage it pretty
bad but but it is it does complicate
things what is your thinking with regard
to this other vegetation or how people
are either going to embrace it or try to
manage these other plants as it pertains
to these mixtures and what weeds we're
getting and how many and part of the
idea behind these mixtures with clover
is that you are potentially have a
little bit more effect on your weeds and
again yes it's gonna make control
difficult
you can't spray much the two Ferdy can
be effective on white clover or not
effective it can be used on white clover
but again we don't know about these
other species of so yes you might get
some more issues but my research last
year showed that I mean obviously we
were spraying pesticides but the grass
only plots head tons more weeds
significantly more weeds than these
clover plots did yeah and we have seen
that we've seen clover keep out
crabgrass in some ways so Carl let's ask
are there any questions about the things
we've been yakking about yeah Dave Dave
Turner and Albany
asking about time of sieving so I don't
know Paige if you have any preferences
or there's any literature that suggests
a certain time to do the clovers even
with scalpin seed process late for the
most part I see that last year we got a
late start so I think soils between 50
and 70 yeah it doesn't seem to be that
different or distinctly different from
cool season grass established it seems
and it'll survive dormant seating so you
can seed in the fall as well which some
of these there will be some perfect okay
Carl other questions yeah that was it I
think I think you guys covered a lot of
ground with the dorms and clover page I
also put a link to your video I know you
guys at Arkansas there's a really well
produced video on the under top dressing
in the worm casting so people are you
sitting that they can check it out
thanks so much for joining us Paige good
luck with your graduate work in this
crazy time they carry cell appreciate
you taking the time thanks Paige and
thanks everybody else for joining us at
LC into two weeks two weeks have two
weeks is our next one and I'll throw a
bee survey again for anybody take care
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu